I want Lady Serena to bear all the guilt of this kidnapping on her own, so that she and the
comfort prince can disappear from the stage of the battle for succession to the throne.
Because Mr. Jeffrey wants to get a lot of
money, and the Lord doesn't choose any means for the purpose.
Ahu is
still in the process of growing.Are you scared even though you're a sars?
[Music]
Give
me a detarame Are you feeling lonely, Katarina-sama, who is kind to Otani
?  I mean, are you actually a good person?
Acting to the other party has become ridiculous, so if it's too deep, I
'll put it back to how it was,
but it's fine as
it is, young lady.
No matter
how I look at it now, I can only see him as an old man from the downtown area, but
it's amazing.